ce qui me frappe c'est qu'il est à
l'aise dans deux exercices il est à
l'aise dans le discours que l'on
pourrait que la presse qualifierais de
jupitérien le discours de de majesté qui
peut te plaindre et le discours sur le
colonel beltrame est absolument parfait
dans ce domaine c'est un discours qui a
vraiment impressionné c'est l'esprit de
la pyramide 1,2 de son discours
inaugural
et il est à l'aise dans autre chose qui
est très important c'est le contact
direct charnel
l'accrochage de la discussion ça a été
le la sphère de de l'amiens entre les
deux tours ça a été quand il parle aux
français que vous aviez quand il va à
fond dans la discussion il cherche comme
de gaulle d'ailleurs de gaulle c'était
pas le dialogue et de nous se lancer
dans les célèbres frontex algérie
française oui hélas il est il étale et
il est il est à la fois supérieure et
proche à ce sont ces deux registres on
trouve la verticalité et l'horizontalité
et il est beaucoup moins à l'aise me
semble-t-il mais je suis un élément un
peu un peu indiscipliné dans la majorité
la réaction dans la relation avec le
parlement